today's show is sponsored by vincero
watches which is an american company
building
super premium wrist watches starting at
only about a hundred and fifty dollars
and they're giving you 15 off when you
go to davidpakman.com
vincero i've put the link underneath
this video today's show
also sponsored by blinkist which is the
app that lets you read or listen to
an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist totally
free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman that link is underneath the
video as well
it's labor day and we're here why are we
here we take federal holidays off we're
here because we're trading labor day for
an entire week off next week we will be
off all of next week
much needed for the staff and then back
with you for the debates and through the
election but good thing we're here today
because one of the biggest stories
of the last couple of months in terms of
its possible impact on the presidential
election broke over the weekend
which has now been quadruply
corroborated despite donald trump
claiming it is all
fake this is a story in which the
atlantic
broke a story uh claiming
that officials who were on a trip with
trump to france
say that trump called troops who died
losers and suckers and it is a hugely
instructive story from the perspective
of the evolution of damage control
because the initial story was just in
the atlantic and it talked about donald
trump repeatedly disparaging the
intelligence of service members
saying keep wounded service members out
of military parades it wouldn't look
good
and it even goes on to say that i don't
know if you remember that incident in
2018 where donald trump decided while in
france
not to go and honor the troops uh at a
cemetery near paris that it was because
of
rain and these individuals who have come
forward said it had nothing to do with
rain
trump was worried his hair would look
bad if it got wet
and he didn't think it was important
again to honor those
who were losers and suckers quoting
trump is saying why should i go to that
cemetery it's filled with losers
trump also during that trip referred to
a conversation
sorry during a conversation referred to
more than 1800 marines
who lost their lives at bella wood
as suckers for getting killed now donald
trump came out and said it's all fake
trump administration officials came out
and said it's all lies
except then the associated press
corroborated it senior defense official
with first-hand knowledge of events
and a senior u.s marine corps officer
said to the associated press
the report in the atlantic is correct
white house continued to
insist it's fake and it's phony and then
cnn triply corroborated it donald trump
referred to fallen u.s service members
in crude and derogatory terms during
that trip in november of 2018 to france
and then they said it's all fake and
then fox news quadruply corroborated it
take a look at this this is
fox news now john i've spoken with two
senior u.s
officials who were on the trip to france
who confirmed to me
key details in the atlantic article and
the quotes attributed to the president
my source a former trump administration
official told me when the president
spoke about the vietnam war
he said it was a stupid war anyone who
went was a sucker
the president would say about american
veterans what's in it for them
they don't make any money the source
said it was a character flaw of the
president he could not understand why
someone would die for their country
not worth it regarding the french trip
to mark the end of world war
one according to this former official
the president was not in a good mood
french president macron had said
something that made him mad
he questioned why he had to go to two
cemeteries why do i have to do two
his staff explained he could cancel but
he was warned
they the press are going to kill you for
this the president was mad
as a hornet when they did according to
this source when asked if the president
could have driven to the ain marn
cemetery this former official said
confidently
that there was not a security reason to
not to drive to the cemetery which was
about 40 miles from paris
quote the president drives a lot the
other world leaders drove to the
cemeteries
he just didn't want to go regarding the
president's july 4
military parade planning during a
planning session at the white house
after seeing the bastille day parade in
2017
president trump said regarding the
inclusion of wounded guys quote that's
not a good look
americans don't like that regarding
senator mccain the president
according to this source just hated john
mccain he always asked
why do you see him as a hero two sources
confirmed the president did not want the
flags lowered after mccain died
but others in the white house ordered
them at half-mast there was a standoff
and then the president relented
that is fox news corroborating and
expanding the story
it's even worse than initially reported
actually based on fox news's additional
reporting
i'm starting to think the story may be
true and of course
it tracks completely with donald trump's
brand and a lot of this stuff he came
close to saying in public
including about john mccain the late
republican senator john mccain
who had been captured um
and held as a prisoner of war donald
trump saying he prefers uh
soldiers who don't get captured and even
tweeted about it i'll tell you about
that in a moment
the internal chaos that this caused at
fox news
fascinating because you had at one point
within hours
the opinion people saying this is all
fake and the news side saying we've been
able to
independently confirm these reports
and trump fundamentally is not able to
understand
the concept of someone doing something
that's not completely self-centered and
greedy
he has an inability to do that and you
know when this story broke you had some
people on the left saying
trump is right these people are suckers
who the hell would join the military
i do think it's important to distinguish
between supporting the troops and
supporting individual wars
and what the military does i recognize
for example
that when george w bush took us into the
harebrained
misguided iraq war we didn't have a
draft in which
i could have been drafted potentially
because we have a volunteer army and
people actually
volunteer now we often send them to the
wrong wars
we use the troops in disgusting ways
for political battles the way george w
bush did
uh but nevertheless i don't think it
makes sense to denigrate
the individuals as the suckers we have a
military industrial complex that is the
problem
we have a deranged foreign policy
apparatus
and you know if if you do believe
that those who go and fight are suckers
tone down the military apparatus trump
has done the opposite
trump simultaneously brags about making
the military bigger than ever
but then says that the individual troops
are suckers and losers when they
actually go
and get killed and why is that it's
because trump
doesn't care about the individuals
in the military but trump is glad to use
the military as an
institution for his benefit when he can
it's very much on brand
in fact could this be trump's 47
moment thinking back to mitt romney in
the 2012 campaign it's possible
this you know a lot of these things that
happen don't
directly relate they don't directly
affect constituencies that trump needs
if this is a case where if you look at
florida and the heavy military presence
in florida and florida being an
important battleground state where
it could determine it certainly is much
more likely than massachusetts or
california to determine the winner
of the presidential election disparaging
the troops in this way to the extent
that people will believe it
could actually make a difference and
again anybody doubting it it's been
quadruply corroborated
it tracks with things donald trump has
said publicly remember
john mccain not a war hero because he
was captured attacking gold star
family the khan family this is only
half a step further than what trump has
done publicly and in fact
donald trump once did retweet that
mccain is a loser
trump retweeting in 2015 an article from
fitznews
donald trump john mccain is a loser
now the stan the perspective there was
the election of 2008
but trump very critical of mccain
including for having been captured
and by the way this is maybe the most
interesting thing pete buudej has done
he was interviewed on fox news about
this story
and he used fox news's own confirmation
of the story
while on fox news against them take a
look at this
again i'm looking at the internet right
now uh fox news itself has confirmed
many of the details of this story so so
the real question is not
to me did trump do this it seems almost
certain that he did the question is
number one what else is going to come
out between now and november because the
atlantic is saying there will be much
more that this is only the tip of the
iceberg and number two
will this affect trump with
constituencies he needs
like the military i believe that it
could
i want to hear from you i'm on twitter
deepakman let me know what you think
could be the
impact of this story the david pakman
show
at davidpakman.com
one of our sponsors today is vincero
watches
and they're giving you 15 off everything
in the store
if you're a guy looking for the perfect
way to refresh your style
one of the best investments you can make
is in a high quality
wrist watch vincero is an american
company
that has made it possible for everyday
people to afford
a premium watch almost everything they
sell is within the range of about two
hundred dollars but it'll look
like you spent a lot more all of their
watches are made in small batches from
top
quality materials and they just look
great i went on their site and picked
out
a watch from their icon automatic
collection the one i got is in mesh
matte black and i love it it's simple
sleek elegant
goes great with just about anything i'm
wearing and i've gotten a ton of
compliments on it
you'll get 15 off everything in their
store
when you go to davidpakman.com vincero
i've put the link right underneath this
[Music]
video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
remember uh in case you've forgotten
because i rarely mention it
we are a program mostly funded and
supported
by members who sign up at joinpakman.com
consider yourself
invited go to joinpacman.com grab a
membership
both joe biden and kamala harris had
very
solid appearances in interviews and
press conferences over the weekend
i'm going to talk about it many of you
have been saying david you know as
important as
as it is to expose the insanity of trump
now that we have a ticket including not
just the presidential nominee but also a
vice presidential nominee
let's highlight what they are doing and
the contrast of sanity that they bring
to the table
and that's exactly what we're going to
do let's start with vp nominee
kamala harris kamala harris was
interviewed by cnn's dana bash
this is one of the first major
interviews that kamala harris did
and i i know that the bar is so low
because of
donald trump and mike pence but kamala
harris
was coherent she met that low bar she
answered the questions she was asked
that's a higher bar for elected
officials who often don't even answer
the questions that they are asked
and she precisely and accurately
expanded on each question
to expose the pathetic failings of the
trump administration
she's not as far left as i am kamala
harris
but it would be a serious breath of
fresh air
just to have people who can speak and
interact coherently
in a position of power after the last
four years but kamala harris does more
than that she actually put on a clinic
in terms of how to be interviewed and
how to answer questions
not dodging but answering
and then doing more so we're going to
look at a few clips of this and the
context i would be thinking about
as you watch the one i was thinking
about is
how is mike pence going to handle kamal
harris during the upcoming debate
and i'm going to tell you a little bit
later on when that debate will be
happening and sort of the details
of it first clip dana bash asks whether
the economic recovery albeit slow is a
threat to biden harris
because as the economy improves it could
pull people back over to donald trump
and kamala harris very quickly gets to
the heart of the issue
which is this is a pandemic you can't
just go around
sacrificing whatever or whoever you need
to
in order to temporarily improve jobs
numbers take a look at her answer
on the economy yeah new jobs numbers out
at the end of the week
uh show that unemployment is 8.4
and not great but about where president
obama had it in 2012.
and so my question is are you worried
despite the fact that it's again not
great
that things are coming back to the point
where where donald trump could have
uh more meat on the bone for his
economic argument that it's coming back
listen i want the american people
to to be able to work i want that we
have jobs
that are filled by the hard-working
people who want to work
and want to have the dignity that comes
with good work
but there is no question that donald
trump has
been an abject failure and incompetent
when it comes to addressing the severe
job loss that has happened as a result
of the pandemic
because he has failed to address the
pandemic itself
and when we look at this path
hopefully at some point to recovery his
perspective cannot be
our perspective because his perspective
for too long is to talk about
how well the economy is doing based on
how rich people are doing
we need to talk about how the economy is
doing based on how working people are
doing
and right now working people are
suffering people are standing
or sitting in their cars in food lines
for hours
what i like about this is that kamala
harris won't allow the conversation
to simply be about the unemployment rate
is now
coming down or stocks are up or we are
getting jobs back that we lost she
points out that's
garbage it ignores why we are here and
that's the big picture that kamala
harris
i hope is going to be able to uh utilize
and expose during the debate with mike
pence
so if she does this with the pence
debate
any time that mike pence points out you
know
august saw some of the best new jobs
numbers
she needs to point out not only is a
partial recovery of what we lost
not that good all of it is much worse
because of the failed
handling of coronavirus then the topic
that comes up is foreign interference
and i like what kamala harris does here
in that
she is asked about russia do you believe
russia's meddling
and we know that there are some people
who reject that idea despite the fact
that
mueller confirmed it the senate select
report confirmed okay
etc there are some people who have sort
of like a visceral reaction anytime
sometimes mentions russia they think
it's a conspiracy theory
and i like what kamala harris does which
she acknowledges that of course russia
is doing this
but she immediately points to the
domestic voter suppression that the
trump administration is engaged in
and won't allow the story or the
question to only be do you believe
russia or not
she knows that just dealing with that
could be a turn off to some viewers and
she says trump
is suppressing the vote take a look at
this russia yeah
the department of homeland security
bulletin
said that russia is trying to amplify
amplify claims that mail-in voting will
lead to widespread
voting fraud and undermine the public's
trust in the upcoming election
are you worried that russian
interference could cost you the election
i am clear that russia interfered in the
election of president of the united
states in 2016.
i serve on the senate intelligence
committee we have published
detailed reports about exactly what we
believe
happened and and i do believe that there
will be foreign interference in the 2020
election
and that russia will be at the front of
the line could it cost you the white
house
theoretically of course yes
and that's based on um what you're
hearing publicly or you mentioned you're
on the side
listen let me just tell you something i
we have to be a realist and i'm a
realist about it joe's a realist about
it
we have classic voter suppression at
play in this election coming up
where after the supreme court gutted
the voting rights act with shelby v
holder in 2013
dozens of states passed laws that were
designed to suppress the black vote
to suppress students from voting to
suppress our indigenous people from
support
from voting so much so that in north
carolina court appeals said it was
the the law was passed with surgical
precision
to to get in the way of black voters
from voting this is a good focus point
that this is a smart thing to focus on
because the idea of the current
administration
suppressing the vote is going to be much
more universally compelling
than an adjudication of to what degree
do you believe russia is doing this or
doing that and what
again what i really like about this
interview is kamala harris answers every
question she doesn't dodge the question
but then she expands with proper context
it's classic
interview and media training answer the
question
and then expand the framing barack obama
was excellent at doing this on the first
question about the economy notice
she was asked what about these improving
job numbers
and she said well improving relative to
the worst numbers we've ever had
and overall much worse because of
trump's failed response
that's how you answer a question here do
you believe russian meddling yeah
i believe russia will meddle and this is
way bigger
because we've got domestic voter
suppression purging of votes
voters in disproportionately black areas
and on and on this is how you actually
deal with issues in interviews now one
more
clip and i encourage you to check out
the full interview kamala harris on
whether she would trust a coronavirus
vaccine
endorsed by donald trump this is crucial
we know that trump's cdc sent out a
letter saying be ready for a vaccine at
the end of october or early november
she has to be careful here kamala harris
does because any time you say you won't
trust a vaccine
you're starting to dabble in maybe being
associated with anti-vaxxerism and
that's not what this is about this is
not about do we trust vaccines in
general
do back vaccines work in general it's is
trump for political reasons
going to try to force something that's
just not yet ready kamala harris does
a perfect job of refocusing the question
promised a coronavirus vaccine by the
end of the year
or maybe sooner would you trust that
vaccine
i think that we have learned since this
pandemic started but really before that
that there's very little that we can
trust that comes out of donald trump's
mouth
from the beginning of this pandemic he
has called it a hoax
he has muzzled the public health experts
he has minimized
the seriousness of it he has created
false expectations
for the american people and american
families even though if he had listened
to the scientists and the experts
he would have understood the gravity of
it and
the power that he is president of the
united states has to actually save lives
and none of those were his priorities
his priority was to
to do whatever he thought was
politically expedient
and um so no i would not trust his word
i would trust the word of public health
experts and scientists but not donald
trump
this is really a clinic on how to answer
it's not
i do or don't trust the vaccine
it's i don't make a decision on whether
the vaccine is okay
on trump's word because trump is
unreliable
it's not about vaccines being the
problem
and getting into maybe oh is she maybe
against vaccines
no it's about i don't trust trump's
word on anything and as a media literacy
person
as a fan of the techniques of
interviewing and
being interviewed this is really well
done by kamal harris i am
very much looking forward to the vp
debate which we'll talk about a little
bit later
okay so it wasn't just kamala harris who
had a great interview this weekend which
which we looked at already
joe biden did an event in delaware about
rebuilding the american economy about
rebuilding the country really once
donald trump is gone
and uh so uh first of all
there are trump people who say biden
won't leave the basement as they like to
say
biden did an event he's not scared to
speak he spoke
perfectly fine seemed far sharper than
donald trump
biden also took media questions again
the trump people say biden won't do it
biden would crumble under questioning
biden doesn't know where he is
he can't put together a sentence didn't
go that way
and joe biden was asked about that trump
conspiracy group
i'm not even going to name it because
youtube instantly demonetizes
if you mention that group youtube
instantly demonetizes it but let me put
it this way
it's related to the letter that comes
after p in the alphabet let's just leave
it there if i'm sure you know what i
mean
and biden is asked about that and biden
just destroys it and goes
very hard and says people need mental
health services now
biden is right about that this is a
crazy group
with outrageous beliefs or claims but
some of the people that
subscribe to those views might get
elected in november
as alex kaplan from media matters told
us last week
which is disturbing to recognize check
out joe biden's response
of the q anon the people who believe in
that conspiracy
what they think is true about america uh
that there's
sex trafficking and a conspiracy against
the
president trump and what would you say
to president trump for
not rejecting that conspiracy
and the people who believe in it
i've been a big supporter of mental
health
i'd recommend the people who believe it
maybe should take advantage while it
still exists
in the affordable care act it's bizarre
totally bizarre and now
have you guys found that plain load of
people in uniforms and weapons and
flying around i mean you know
have you found them yet is anybody even
from by the way i respect conservative
and liberal points of view in the press
anybody found that plane
what in god's name are we doing
look at how it makes us look around the
world
it's mortified it's embarrassing and
it's dangerous
it's dangerous
if the president doesn't know better
which i he has
to know better and my lord we're in much
more trouble than i ever thought we were
it's bizarre what in god's name are we
doing
is sort of in my mind the slogan for the
last four years it's a relevant phrase
not just when it comes to this group
but it's a relevant phrase big picture
for the administration joe biden
very clearly saying what many of us what
many in my audience have been thinking
which is
how does the entire country not realize
what the world realizes
which is that we are a laughingstock
with donald trump in the white house we
have become a joke
joe biden's saying it and then joe biden
again
showing more energy this weekend than
we've seen from him in a while
because he was very fired up about the
story
that donald trump said troops who died
in combat are
losers and suckers biden
visibly furious and disgusted with
donald trump this is a couple minutes
almost but i want to show you the entire
answer quite frankly
if what is written in the atlantic is
true it's disgusting
and it affirms what most of us believe
to be true
that donald trump is not fit to be the
job of president be the
commander-in-chief
the president reportedly said and i
emphasize reportedly said
that those who sign up to serve instead
of doing something more lucrative are
suckers
let me be real clear when my son was an
assistant u.s attorney and he
volunteered to go to kosovo
while the war was going on as a civilian
he wasn't a sucker when my son
volunteered and joined the united states
military
as the attorney general and went to iraq
for a year
won the bronze star and other
commendations
he wasn't a sucker
the service men and women he served with
particularly those did not come home
were not
losers if these statements are true
the president should humbly apologize
to every gold star mother and father
and every blue star family that he's
denigrated and sold it
who the heck does he think he is
if it's true and based on other things
he said i believe the article is true
i'd ask you all the rhetorical question
how do you feel
how would you feel if you had a kid in
afghanistan right now
how would you feel
if you lost a son daughter husband wife
this was also really instructive to
uh from the standpoint of what i call
dds
democratic derangement syndrome you
simultaneously had
republicans criticizing that answer for
diametrically opposed reasons
you had some republicans saying oh my
goodness
joe biden's unhinged he's going crazy
about fake news and then you had other
republicans
who because the story has been quadruply
corroborated believe the story
saying what's wrong with biden biden
should have been more mad it almost
seems like he was
uh a low energy he could barely
even really get that that's weird why
wasn't biden more furious
about the comment if he believes that
he's does he not support the troops
so if you take every side of an issue as
donald trump and trump as typically do
you've got this sort of something for
everybody framing
which i've mentioned for some time uh
remember
joe biden said right before super
tuesday
we have to beat trump and the
republicans
but we can't become like them and i
think that
in our criticism of donald trump about
this suckers and losers thing
in our continued exploration of donald
trump's
you know denial of strokes that nobody
actually accused him of having
in all of this we have to make sure that
we don't become like them i tend to
agree with joe biden i want to win
but if we win the way they win have we
really won
and i've talked about this before and i
think it's something to keep in mind
especially as we get closer to the
debates which i'll be talking about next
just imagine if we see a fired up joe
biden at the debates
i don't think it will come off as
unhinged i think it will come off as
genuine and it will actually reflect the
feelings of many in this country
including some of us
who know that when every week is a
scandal
you start to become a little
desensitized so i was glad to see this i
think we're going to see more of it
make sure you're following us on
instagram at david pakman show
while you're there follow me on
instagram at david.pakman you can see
some of my recent prepping
elements that i've purchased quick break
back after this
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks a month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
welcome back to the david pakman show
okay what i have for you next
i have to admit this is a pleasure to
watch i am
really enjoying the entire trump
administration
just falling all over itself to try to
deny
this blockbuster bombshell story about
donald trump calling
troops who died in combat losers and
suckers i already told you when the
atlantic reported it trump denied it
then the ap corroborated it they kept
denying it fox confirmed it
chaos at fox news cnn now has quadruply
confirmed it
and they have no idea what to do and at
one of those gong show press briefings
friday
trump said both that the source for the
story
doesn't exist and that the sources for
the story are lying so hey hold on
are they real and lying or they don't
exist and are made up by the media
outlets
all four media outlets which is it and
this is amazing and trump
barely able to speak you will hear him
say here three and a half years
it just makes no sense he's making no
sense i've gone after me more than any
president in the united states in
history
in the history of the united states and
it's a shame
it's a shame and despite that we've done
more in the first three and a half years
than any administration there's been no
administration that's done more when you
add it all up there's been no
despite all of the horrible political
games that have been played
but there's nobody that's been
that's been able to do what i've done
and that includes the great mission act
because what obama passed was a joke
it was a joke and we took it to a level
that nobody thought possible
and that includes accountability so it's
a disgrace that somebody's allowed to
write things like that it could have
been you know a lot of times the sources
aren't sources that don't exist and
sometimes the sources are just
people that are disgruntled former
so-called employees
as aaron rupar said on twitter it's a
sort of choose your own adventure here
is it
there are fake sources made up by the
media outlets all four
or is it that these are disgruntled
former employees who are lying the grief
briefing didn't get any better here
trump started to attack his former chief
of staff john kelly on the suspicion
that john kelly might be the source but
the question trump was asked was
did you disparage american soldiers and
trump
instead of denying it attacks john kelly
and then says
that also the weather was the reason why
he wasn't able to go
to that cemetery in france the fog
prevented him from going to honor the
troops
a claim which has been widely debunked
since and even
able to function in the last number of
months he was not able to function
he was sort of a tough guy by the time
he got
eaten up in this world it's a different
world than he was used to
he was unable to function and i told him
john you're going to have to go
please give me a letter of resignation
and we did that
and now he goes out and badmouths now
there are people that are
jealous there are people that are upset
that they're not here anymore
there are people we've done an
incredible job the virus came in and now
we're doing an incredible job again
we're going to build it up bigger than
it was before the virus came in
but i don't know that it was him i
haven't seen that i mean i see anonymous
but it could have been a guy like a john
kelly
because he was because just so you
understand
he was a very
you look at some of his news conferences
what happened to him he got eaten alive
he was unable to handle the pressure of
this job this job
was a tough job mark meadows doing a
great job
but kelly was unable to do that and as
far as that day i mean we have
so much proof as to going to
the we i went to paris and the environs
and i was all set to go they had a
rainstorm the likes of which you've
rarely seen
the fog was so great it was it was as
dense as i've ever seen
just unable to stick to any topic
ever then trump said again that the
atlantic story is a hoax
ignoring of course that at this point it
had been corroborated by the ap
and fox news and after this briefing by
cnn
as well i know you spoke earlier about
the atlantic story and you
referenced the number of administration
officials who have come out
to support you know we have 11 people i
was just told
i was just we have 11 people there is
nobody that feels
more strongly about our soldiers our
wounded warriors
are soldiers that died in war than i do
it's a hoax just like the fake dossier
was a hoax
just like the russia russia russia was a
hoax it was a total hoax
no collusion just like so many other
things
it's a hoax and you'll hear more of
these things totally unrelated
as we get closer and closer to election
the magazine is a failing magazine
and nobody called me nobody called me
from the magazine said you have a
comment about it no they just write
whatever they want to write
because they figure you can't get sued
you can't get sued but it's very
it's a very hard bringing lawsuit of
course the other things
trump mentions also aren't hoaxes the
dossier was real with lots of accurate
things and many things that are still
unconfirmed
the russia thing was not a hoax dozens
were arrested the mueller report
couldn't exonerate trump
the senate select report pointed out
that a lot of the allegations were true
so none of them were hoaxes
and then trump wrapping up hilariously
by assailing the reporters in the room
as children asking terrible questions
and then
bizarrely thanking them for their
presence biden
getting asked questions
that are really meant for a child to
answer anybody could answer
and i look at the level of question that
you people ask i mean honestly it's
disgraceful
so i want to thank you all very much we
appreciate it
and we're doing very well we're very
very proud of what's happened with
respect to the economy i i just love
that your questions are childish
you people are disgraceful thank you
very much for being here at my press
briefing which couldn't exist
without you actually being here this is
a man falling apart
and this was only part of the press
briefing i want to kind of separate it
into stuff related to the soldier's
story
and then other things that happened at
the rally i'm sorry
that's a freudian slip other things that
happened at the briefing
uh right after this because there is
much more to discuss
so now that we've looked specifically
at donald trump's press briefing
comments about the horrifying atlantic
story
which has now been quadruply
corroborated by the ap fox news and cnn
there's a ton of other material from
this weird press briefing that i want to
go over
especially because kamala harris in her
interview on cnn which we looked at
discusses a lot of the material from
this press briefing so
this first clip this is just incoherent
i don't know what trump is saying here
can you figure out what he's talking
about
now they want to stop regulations they
want to
bring up regulations to a level stop the
things that we're doing which are at a
much smaller level and bring up
regulations at a level that nobody's
ever seen before they want to do it i
beg you
try to figure out what donald trump is
talking about there
donald trump then absurdly claims
that economic shutdowns to combat the
virus
kill more people than the virus itself
now i'm going to deal with the numbers
in a moment first take a look at what
trump said
want to abolish american energy i mean
that's what's going to happen
adopt disastrous trade deals and inflict
a devastating shutdown
as you know he said we want to shut it
down we would be willing to shut it down
and you don't shut down when we're
setting records and by the way we're
rounding the corner
we're rounding the corner on the virus
joe biden's blanket shut down would
collapse our economy would cause
countless deaths from suicide drug
alcohol abuse
heart disease and more you know
shutdowns cause a lot of problems
a lot of very serious problems more so
than the virus itself
so we're approaching 200 000 deaths from
coronavirus
the shutdowns have obviously not caused
200 000 deaths or anywhere close to it
now
let's be thorough are deaths of despair
a thing
yes of course we've reported on that on
this program they've been a problem in
the united states
for economic reasons for a long time
deaths of despair are a real thing
can later diagnoses of cancer for
example
or other conditions because people are
opting out of going to the doctor right
now
can that lead to premature death of
course it can
of course can being in quarantine caused
somebody to commit suicide
it could happen but we've had 200
000 coronavirus deaths it's insulting to
suggest
that that is uh not as bad
as the number of deaths we've had due to
the shutdowns
it's ludicrous and it's laughable then
donald trump again suggests this idea
that states that are closed or closed
for political reasons to hurt him
and that the day after the election
they're all going to open take a look
north carolina i think that michigan
and pennsylvania and other states they
should open the governors of democrat
governors should open the states they'll
open them on november 4th
but that should open them now it's very
unfair to the people to have those
shutdowns continuing
at the level that they're continuing
democrats are insisting on it the
shutdowns
two things on this number one the
shutdowns aren't really continuing i
mean to different degrees even
massachusetts which is being very
careful and there's like sort of limited
indoor dining not every restaurant's
doing it
a lot of colleges are going remote
there's really no no full shutdowns
going on at this point in time and of
course the shutdowns were not done for
political reasons
no governor is on november 4th going to
say
hey we can now open wide open now but we
can now open wide
uh that's another trump fantasy it's not
going to happen
then trump spoke about the vaccine again
this is tracking with a lot of what
kamala harris talked about in her
interview with cnn
trump says we can probably have the
vaccine
during october and you might have
noticed that trump's timeline for the
vaccine keeps getting pushed up more and
more
percent more greater excess mortality
than the united states a lot of you
don't want to report that
and if we took new york out of the
equation there's nobody even close the
job we've done is incredible and
we don't get any credit for it but we've
done an incredible job through operation
warp speed we have
three vaccines in the final stage of
clinical trials yesterday pfizer
announced i just spoke to the head of
pfizer
great guy they announced that it expects
to have the results of its
trial very very shortly next month
but very shortly we remain on track to
deliver a vaccine before the end of the
year and maybe even before
november 1st we think we could probably
have it sometime
during the month of october and pfizer
is
among the leaders as you know kamala was
asked
would you trust the vaccine that a trump
fda approves in october
and she said i don't trust trump and it
is not about anti-vaxxer
it's about trump being the constant liar
then and this is just wild trump on
social distancing listen to this and
i'll tell you why it's crazy in a moment
and we need everybody to be careful to
apply common sense
and do all of the things that we've told
you to do
as quickly as much as you can
social distancing wearing a mask when
ever the distancing is not
possible and staying like
staying with a group that you know let's
just try and get through this
one weekend and i think we have a chance
of doing that just
social distance wash your hands all of
the hygiene things that we speak about
and we're really rounding the turn so
trump says that
but trump is doing rallies trump just
did a rally in latrobe pennsylvania
everybody standing together no masks
huge crowd
no covid tests no hand washing everybody
crammed into a tight space to wait for
donald trump to show up
he's saying at press briefings masks
space between people all this stuff
and then he's holding optional events
where it is impossible to do it
lastly trump or a couple more clips
trump can't under
understand the english of the same
indian reporter
who's been there for years with the
press corps trump tells him he didn't
catch anything other than india
thank you mr president bring the
conventions
uh thank you right in the conventions
kimberly and don julia
had outreach to the indian american
community with a video called
four more years for you which has gone
viral among indian americans
the battleground states so my question
is would kimberly don jr and ivanka
trump who are very popular now indian
americans
would be campaigning on your behalf
among the indian americans with your
abuse or india university
well i didn't understand everything you
said i know india
trump only understood india there you go
and then the reporter tries again
and all trump can say is he likes india
and they like him in india
and india is a very big country
so my question was about indian
americans do you think they are voting
for you for
are you are they supporting you i do we
had a an event
in houston as you know and it was a
fantastic event i was invited by
prime minister modi and this was a
massive this was at the
where they play football houston
football team
and it was uh it was it was incredible
it was actually incredible and
the prime minister could not have been
more generous we have
great support from india we have great
support from
prime minister modi and i would think
that the people
indian people would be voting for trump
i also
as you know went to india just prior to
the pandemic setting
in because india's been hit very hard
left really
about a week before that and we had an
incredible time
what what we saw the people are so
incredible
it's really an incredible place an
incredible country and it's definitely
big
it's definitely big trump also adds in
that if the indian people were given the
opportunity they would
they would vote trump this is
indistinguishable from parity
this is impossible to satirize what does
how does snl
make a parody of a press briefing like
that
we cannot withstand much more of this we
really can't we have to remove this guy
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous bonus show as well as commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent vote
soon 18.
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so we've now confirmed not just the
dates but also the moderators and the
locations of the upcoming three
presidential debates and the one vice
presidential debate
and joe biden is demanding live fact
checking during the debates which
obviously donald trump
will oppose but we're going to get to
that in a minute
uh there's still some debate over
whether one or or both of the candidates
are going to back out you have some
trumpists
saying biden's gonna find a way out that
biden
cognitively can't do it he would be
crushed by trump's
incredible intellect and cognitive
abilities and that biden will find some
way out he'll say a few days before the
event that he has coveted or something
like that
i don't think that that's going to
happen i think biden very much
understands that not debating
would not be particularly good for him
on the other hand
there are those who think trump is going
to try to find some way out either
because he'd be scared that
he won't be able to do to biden what he
did to hillary clinton in terms of kind
of stalking behind her and standing
physically close and that
i i think that they're probably going to
debate if i had to bet
now the debates are going to be on fox
news c-span and nbc
cnn shut out of the debates for the
first time since 2008
looking at the details september 29th
chris wallace will moderate a debate on
fox news
in cleveland ohio it will have six
15-minute segments
with two minutes per question i'm going
to get to that in a moment
on october 7th there will be a vp debate
susan page from usa today will be
moderating it it'll be at the university
of utah in salt lake city it will be
nine 10-minute segments two minutes per
question
the second presidential will be on
october 15th steve scully from c-span
will do it in miami florida
it'll be a town minute format with two
minutes per question
with an additional minute as needed and
then lastly the third debate will be
moderated by kristen welker of nbc
on october 22nd that's very close to
voting day
same format as the first debate so a few
thoughts first of all
the format favors donald trump anything
shorter
favors trump and you really can't do
anything
in two or three minutes i mean the the
issues that these individuals are
dealing with
are complex issues where if you had a
deep understanding of them you would
want
three to four minutes just to lay out
that you understand the issue that's how
you would have serious conversation
these debates are not set up for
information purposes
these debates are set up for
entertainment purposes and
the shorter it is the more it favors
donald trump because
i believe it's clear joe biden is the
one able to go deeper
in terms of policy than donald trump so
that's number one now number two
um the late debates the trump
administration has been trying to push
or the trump campaign for an additional
debate early this month
because they recognize the more people
vote early
the fewer people left to convince will
be remaining
on october 22nd and that's true i do
think that
on october 22nd you're going to have a
smaller portion of the electorate
arguably than in any prior election due
to early voting and expanded absentee
ballot access
that probably is good for joe biden
in the sense that it's trump who is
likely to pull
some kind of october surprise and the
more people that have already sent
in their ballots or voted early whenever
trump pulls it
the less effective it's going to be for
him now on the fact checking biden
previously said
he wants some kind of live fact checking
of the president on screen
trump's obviously against it it doesn't
seem like it's going to happen and so
it's going to be up to
joe biden to do the fact checking um
i don't need debates this year i've said
it it's never been clearer to me who we
should be supporting
but for those who want to see debates
and again they'll be entertaining i
don't think they'll be super informative
we will be doing live streams of all
four
the three presidential and the one vp
debate i think the vp debate
kamala harris is just going to eat mike
pence up and spit him out i just don't
see any way
in which pence gets through it unscathed
unscathed his followers won't care
they'll refuse to acknowledge it but i
think it's going to be very very bad for
mike pence
so donald trump continues to deny that
he had many strokes and again
this is only raising more questions
because the upcoming
book from michael schmidt from the new
york times
doesn't allege trump had strokes and
trump continuing to bring it up it's
starting to put more
attention on it than there would be
otherwise and the back
story of course is that michael
schmidt's book
claims that when donald trump abruptly
went to walter reed hospital in 2019 for
that unscheduled visit
that it was some kind of urgent medical
situation he doesn't say what kind it
was
but he does say that mike pence was put
on notice be prepared
to take over as president because donald
trump
may need to go under anesthesia trump
has brought up this issue of many
strokes which is not a claim that's
actually made in the book trump
introduces the idea of strokes in a
tweet last week
where he said quote it never ends now
they are trying to say that your
favorite president me
went to walter reed medical center
having suffered a series of mini strokes
never happened to this candidate fake
news
perhaps they're referring to another
candidate from another party
then trump brings it up again during
this latrobe
pennsylvania corona rally which i
covered last week
trump spent several minutes on this
again telling this totally implausible
story
that he said hey you know what let's go
over to walter reed
last minute to get a jump on next year's
physical it was never believable but
again
trump brings up mini strokes take a look
at this
[Applause]
no but the new one is you know i went
for a physical the doctor said to me sir
would you like to go over to walter reed
it's incredible by the way
the job they do on people that have been
just really hurt are heroes
and the job they do is incredible but
sir would you like to go over and do a
physical
you have some time you know why i had
time some deal oh it was china
i decided not to see china because they
didn't like the way they were doing
business okay
does that make sense so the doctor white
house doctor
highly respected sean sean connolly sir
would you like to go over and do
your physical or do a piece of it or
finish it or whatever it was but do a
physic
i said i don't know i'm not in love with
the idea well let's if you do it we
don't have to do it so okay let's go
come on
so we went way one and we're driving now
you have to understand there are like
you know 100 cars you see what happens
here it's like the plane times
50. so the cars are driving all over
it's about a 20-minute drive
and we get to the hospital i get out i
was there probably for an hour and a
half two hours
and then yesterday i read that i had
strokes
cnn fake news cnn right there
[Applause]
no it's true many strokes they called
them
i don't know what a mini stroke is but
it's not good
and there could be a day and donald
admit i said hey it happens to all of us
right
except these young ones it's never going
to happen to them they're not looking at
that but you know what happens
but nothing happened so i went in i did
that part of the physical the end result
was he's very healthy
they're very unhappy when they heard
that result so
first first of all imagine that this is
the behavior of an american president
just let
let that sink in for a second but going
further than that
you know sometimes people will write to
me they'll say david why do you keep
making a big deal out of this
totally outrageous behavior given that
it's so common and we've become so used
to it
that's exactly why we should not be used
to it
and we cannot allow this type of
insanity to be normalized that's why i
keep talking about it
to try to fight the normalization to get
back to the main
topic this is crazy
because trump keeps bringing up how he
didn't have strokes
nobody alleged that he had strokes now i
know it's been speculated
by random people but the allegations
in the book that trump is responding to
don't mention strokes
it's sort of like when trump started to
bizarrely focus in on acing his
cognitive test
which is a test that is not difficult
and it's just meant to screen out
serious dementia trump calling it a
difficult test
it's wild stuff it is unforced errors
trump talking about he and biden should
take
drug tests before debates because maybe
biden took something before his debate
with bernie
the speculation of course is that it's
trump who sometimes seems all hopped up
with the dilated pupils and the sweating
it's constant projection of this kind
and
it's now become almost like we're headed
to some kind of boxing match
with a weigh-in anti-doping screenings
more so than we are
presidential debates uh as far as the
strokes go
why does trump keep talking about it
doesn't this just raise the suspicion
even more that he's constantly now
talking about strokes
nobody claimed that he had very very
strange stuff
and listen my position is the following
i don't know what happened to trump on
that day
what i do know is that the story of
saying hey you know what
let's right now like right now let's
drive over to walter reed to get a jump
on my physical for next year
and spend hours there it doesn't make
sense
it doesn't pass the sniff test that's
what i can tell you
the fact that trump keeps mentioning
strokes is certainly weird
if not concerning we have a voicemail
number
that number is 2192 david p
this voicemail is a good voicemail aside
from being disgusting
to talk about what we can control and
what we cannot control take a listen to
this
put this on your freaking stupid
sideshow
you you know you're nothing but a greasy
venezuelan
why don't you go back there and grease
that place up and you sit there
and you throw your hands around you know
what you look like a wounded
freaking chicken you're an [ __ ] and
the biden is going to lose and lose big
so screw you you ass there you go
so of course on the facts i've never
been to venezuela i'm argentinian
i am not a fan of the hugo uh chavez
nicholas maduro regime i have no real
interest
in going to venezuela period so that's
number one that's just sort of that
xenophobia of
listen south america it's all kind of
the same doesn't really matter
etc okay this is an opportunity to talk
about what we can and we cannot control
because the caller does say
biden's going to lose and he's going to
lose big and i think that
in this moment in time it is a very
uh sort of good opportunity to
understand
the teachings of the stoics i'm talking
about
marcus aurelius i'm talking about seneca
i'm talking about i don't know if it's
pronounced
epictetus or epictetus where we need to
understand that there are really three
categories
of things in the world they are the
things over we at which we have total
control like for example
i can have total control about my over
my goals i
i decide what are my goals i have
complete control there are things over
which i have no control like is the sun
going to rise tomorrow i have no control
over that there's no point in worrying
about that and thinking about that
and then there's the area over which we
have some control
the election is one of those cases i can
control
the message i put out on this program i
can control how i vote
i can control whether i make the best
effort possible to convince
people that they should vote and they
should vote for joe biden
but that's as far as my control goes and
you know all of this stuff
about people expecting me to cry on
election night if biden doesn't win
i'm going to be very sad because of what
it means for our country
but i'm going to know i did everything i
could
and then we'll just have to proceed
forward right life will go on
it will be a worse life certainly for
the average person
if joe biden doesn't win but uh you know
all these people with these personal
vendettas they want to see
me cry on election night this is not
about me
this is not about me but i do think it's
a good opportunity for us to understand
where does our sphere of influence end
and as long as we feel that we did
everything we could
that's as far as we really have control
something to keep in mind in advance of
whatever the results are on november 3rd
or whatever day we find out the results
we've got a great bonus show for you
today we will talk about
labor day as a possible coronavirus
spike event
we will talk about young americans
living at home with their parents
in greater numbers than we've seen for a
long time since the great depression in
fact
and much more get access to today's
bonus show
and every bonus show by becoming a
member
at joinpakman.com
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's program
was made possible by vincero
watches the american watchmaker building
super quality wrist watches but
making them affordable for everyday
people and they're giving you 15 percent
off when you go to davidpakman.com
vincero today's show also sponsored by
blinkist blinkist is the app that lets
you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book
in 15 minutes and you can try blinkist
for free and get 25 percent off a
subscription when you go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put that link down
below
underneath the video